hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast procalcitonin and
emergency department patients this
respected kovin 19 presented by dr.
Charles Caron I am michelle ashen of
Labatt's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labyrinth
brought to you by beer mare you for more
information on our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit ID laughs now like to
introduce our presenter dr. Charles
Caron the Walter H and Lana Annenberg
Dean of the College of Medicine and
senior vice president for medical
affairs at Drexel University
not enough it is currently exists that
stars Kovach's the virus that causes
Koba 19 acts any different than any
viruses with respect to procalcitonin
level by this Brahms PCT is not cleared
for the detection of SARS Kobe - and is
not indicated to be used as a standalone
diagnostic assay and should be used in
conjunction with clinical signs and
symptoms of infection and other
diagnostic evidence
thank you very much Michelle
is being sponsored by beer vo Mary you
and I do serve on the boards of
directional university physicians st.
Christopher hospital for children in
Philadelphia as well as on the National
Foundation of emergency medicine
the objectives of today's talk are to
one better understand the host response
to bacterial and viral infections to
understand the rationale for the
assessment of procalcitonin in patients
with suspected infections and three to
understand approaches to assessing the
host response to infection in patients
with suspected kovin 19 in the emergency
department including the potential role
of cassutto
let's start with a host response to
infection clearly the host response is a
complex system dynamic it involves
interactions between the pathogen the
immune system and inflammation
furthermore the hosts response is
characterized by distinctive phenotypes
particularly in response to viral versus
bacterial infections and they does vary
across individuals frankly it also
varies across time and so what is seen
at one point during an infection and
host response may change dramatically
over time some of these responses can be
adaptive some of them can be maladaptive
and then finally we're going to
highlight in particular how the host
response differs between bacterial and
viral infections
other great classification schemes for
understanding the intersection between
infection and inflammation or the
chemical response in the immune system
as part of the hosts response to
infection was put forward by Roger bone
back in 1992 in this construct you have
the Venn diagram that intersects
infection in this case yellow shown with
inflammation and and Rogers construct
this was called systemic inflammatory
response syndrome or sirs and that's
shown in red so inflammation can occur
without infection and there are a number
of disease states in fact one of the
first findings were serves was in
pancreatitis but it's also semen burns
and trauma however we're very interested
on the intersection between infection
and inflammation that results in disease
states like sepsis or severe sepsis
because these are typically the states
were more severe most responses to
infection have occurred
further highlight than this intersection
between infection inflammation and time
is this graph now I took this graph out
of the burn literature but it could also
apply to trauma and it could also apply
to infection and the idea is on the
vertical axis we have immune function
with those lines above the broad
horizontal line being pro-inflammatory
and those below the broad line being
anti-inflammatory and then on the
horizontal axis we have hours and days
and so if you start thinking about
measures of inflammation after a burn
injury there's a marked pro-inflammatory
response as the cells are injured in a
cascade occurs that brings inflammatory
elements to it that's then followed by a
period of anti inflammatory response as
the body begins to readapt its immune
response to these damaged areas this
leads a course to susceptibility to
infection which can be catastrophic and
deadly and burn patients as well as
trauma patients and then leads to a
recovery phase where the immune response
again it gets more closer to normal and
in the case of burns can be a challenge
if you're doing skin grafting and have
rejection skin graft is inflammation to
imagine that you have an intervention
that's anti-inflammatory and you give it
during the first few hours when the
pro-inflammatory time is there you now
have an agent that's directed against
the inflammation and you have a shot at
showing a difference but imagine if you
give the exact same anti-inflammatory
drug during the anti-inflammatory fades
same patient same injury same condition
but now a different stage that the
inflammatory response it could be
catastrophic leading to infections and
potentially untoward events so
understanding the dynamic of the
inflammatory response to a host injury
or host infection is a key component
of understanding the overall impact of
infections or injury on people we've
actually looked at this in terms of
emergency department patients and this
is done in conjunction with my
colleagues at Duke and in Henry Ford and
at the University of North Carolina and
what we looked at was to determine at a
single point in the emergency department
the T zero on the horizontal axis of
this graph
what happens to people's course after
infection do they go ahead to have an
uncomplicated course do they have one in
which they develop sepsis severe sepsis
has the Morgan compromised or recover do
they go on to have severe complications
of sepsis including hypotension
cardiovascular collapse consistent with
septic shock or did they go on to die
from sepsis and understanding the host
response at that period of time in these
patients was a key challenge of this
study we've had numerous publications on
it but I'm going to highlight some key
findings
on this slide the first finding we have
is that there are many biochemical
differences between sepsis and
non-infected inflammation in other words
we could take that construct that Roger
bone have and determine those people had
inflammation without infection whereas
those people at inflammation with
infections
the next key component was to determine
could we predict who had sepsis death
versus those who survived and indeed we
could on that single point in time we
could determine those on a trajectory
for death versus those drawers and
trajectory of survival including those
who develop septic shock and severe
sepsis so clearly there was something
fundamentally different in the host
response among those who survived though
Saddam
when you start drilling down this
perspective and this was all published
in Science Translational Medicine in
2013 we were able to take a look at how
well this prediction based on these
metabolic and biochemical differences
were first of things like organ scores
in this case Apache or the sofa scores
I'm not going to go into this slide into
much detail but on the right side on the
upper right part you see a receiver
operating curve a classic sensitivity
I'm vertical axis horizontal axis 1
minus specificity a perfect test will be
on that upper left-hand corner 100%
sensitivity and then 0 for the 1 minus
specificity because it's 100% specific
and you really want to have a test
that's going to be greater than the
point 7 for the area under the curve and
you can see that when you look at Oregon
failure scores you do have areas under
the curve above point 7 but now I want
you to take a look at the curve right
below it this is now going to
incorporate the prediction based on this
biochemical difference and at that
single point in time we could get areas
under the curve that were remarkable
above point 9 0 and we get closer and
closer that 100% sensitivity and
specificity and some of the key
classifiers or things you're used to
like mean arterial pressure lactate
which are frequently used in sepsis but
also some pretty novel metabolic
measurements
in fact we looked at not only the
multiple eyes that were novel but also
the proteins and so this combination are
looking at proteomics and metabolomics
given gives us a system view of the host
response and again I'm not going to go
into this in detail the paper was
published in Science Translational
Medicine
but the key components are you can see
these areas in this graph were red and
blue highlight showing the direct
interaction between proteins which cell
structures and metabolites or the
cellular biochemical response to
infection and inflammation and this has
led to new pathway identification but
most importantly it allowed us to
distinguish the host responses survival
from that of non survival next time
furthermore I've done studies where we
looked at genomic expression and so
these are which genes in which gene
products are expressed in response to
inflammation and we saw some pretty
dramatic differences this was then
published in genome medicine in 2014 on
the first column you see serves or the
systemic inflammatory response syndrome
the second one our sepsis patients who
didn't survive and then the third one on
the far right our sepsis survivors and
you could see when you start looking at
the genomic expression patterns for each
of these patients and then the different
expression is put in blue or red
depending on whether it goes up or down
you can see there's a clear distinction
between those who had serves and
survived without infection those who had
infections and didn't survive in the
middle and those who had infections and
survived in red so clearly we can
characterize a survival response
inflammatory response to an infection on
both proteins Cabell omics and now
genomics
we've used this classification scheme to
publish the difference between these
expressions in patients will confirm by
role infections versus bacterial
infection this is data that we presented
another Science Translational Medicine
paper now in 2006 where we able to take
a look at those with bacterial
infections viral infections and probable
non-infectious causes and begin to
realize that the viral components which
are in dark triangles excuse me in the
bacterial ones in dark triangles start
to distinguish themselves as being
higher than those classifies it
bacterial that's the first column those
viral components blue circles come out
and those classified as viral and then
you could see in the healthy group the
third column that those non-infectious
characteristics in the green circles
come prominent and so we begin to be
able to classify again based on this
host response alone those four bacterial
infection viral infections and those who
are healthy we also took a look at those
with not infectious causes and could
even see some distinction of those I
think most interesting aspect of that is
that the healthy profiles were very low
so there is an inherent response of the
host beyond just bacterial and viral
infections
when we put these together though
clinically how do we use it and so this
is a paper we recently published in E
biomedicine last year using this
classification structure for bacteria
for virus and then for non-infectious
causes and you can see when you start
looking at these profiles you can really
do
fairly accurate classification of
bacterial infections in this area under
a curve approaching nine point nine
viral classify tzer's again very high
area under the curve and even
classifying those that don't have
infectious causes of inflammation so I
think the bottom line this is that
you're able to classify patients
prospectively based on the host response
in terms of genomics metabolomic and
proteomics
the last component before we switch over
specifically the calcitonin is to look
at the ability a complex disease of
these classifiers in this case
superimposed bacterial infection on top
of a primary viral disease and using
these classifiers we are able to take a
look at patients who had Co infection
and when you started looking at the
bacterial which is in red versus viral
components which are in black you can
see that bacterial infections have a
marked pattern particularly in the red
components co-infection we see a
distribution between red and black and
then by the time we get to viral
infections it's predominantly black so
there may be value and understanding not
just specific bacterial disease or viral
disease but there may be an opportunity
to determine patients who have
co-infection with viral and bacterial
disease clearly this will become
important as we consider kovat 19
patients
let's move on to procalcitonin the
procalcitonin is a prohormone of
calcitonin it can be deuced by produced
by numerous cell types and organs after
pro-inflammatory stimulation especially
those caused by bacterial challenge and
healthy individuals procalcitonin
concentrations are thought to be less
than 0.5 nanograms per milliliter and
numerous studies have shown that
elevated procalcitonin levels indicate
bacterial infection accompanied by
systemic inflammatory reaction
to illustrate the host response that
procalcitonin reflects I think is
illustrated in this this study published
by Reinhardt back in 2011 in response to
a bacterial endotoxin challenge and you
could see that right after on the on the
horizontal accent we we have time in
hours on the vertical axis we have
plasma concentration of various markers
including il-6 il-10 - necrosis factor
TNF as well as procalcitonin PCT and
c-reactive protein CRP and you can see
that after about two hours after
injection of endotoxin you see a marked
rise in procalcitonin
it falls off over 48 to 72 hours and
then followed a couple hours maybe four
hours later by this rise and see
reactive proteins this is evidence of a
bacterial host response that is found by
procalcitonin
so how does procalcitonin look in this
overall schema a viral versus bacterial
infection well in our paper in a
biomedicine we also use procalcitonin as
a potential marker for bacterial
infection and is its own independent
classifier and we found that
procalcitonin did distinguish bacterial
infection with a relatively good
response and similar to our classifiers
with areas under the curve that that are
certainly above the point-seven
threshold so this suggested to us that
our classifiers which we went through
can distinguish bacterial viral not
infectious and that procalcitonin was
certainly performing a host response
detection characteristic of bacterial
infections
has also looked at the use of other
biomarkers in sepsis this is a paper
that we published in the journal
emergency medicine back in 2012 looking
at procalcitonin in a wide range of
emergency department patients with
septic sepsis and we found that
procalcitonin performed certainly well
with a area under curve of 0.78 when
measured of sensitivity on the vertical
axis and one - specificity on the
horizontal axis other things we looked
at by the way included il-6 or classic
mark of inflammation c-reactive protein
and we did use organ dysfunction scores
like Apache
so the comments about procalcitonin use
in the emergency department would be
that procalcitonin has been one of the
most studied biomarkers and current
times and when I did my PubMed search on
procalcitonin it showed five thousand
six hundred and ninety two references
admittedly I didn't search it for human
trials admittedly I didn't search it for
a you see the emergency department the
clearly thousands upon thousands of
studies procalcitonin performed in fact
when you look at meta-analysis there
have been four men analyses alone over
the past year which have consistently
showed the use of antibiotics with
significantly reduced for procalcitonin
in patients with sepsis or lower
respiratory tract infections there have
been two large and important a
randomised trials performed in Mercy
apartment which failed to demonstrate
antibiotic reductions with procalcitonin
it's interesting when you look at that
those studies though because they didn't
involve as many patients as we might see
in clinical practice with that confirmed
bacterial infections rates in pneumonia
and most certainly those requiring ICU
care and so recent meta-analysis in 2019
looked at mortality of using
procalcitonin guided antibiotics in
critically ill patients and I think this
is important to focus in on in the age
of kovat nineteen
in this study that was out of the NIH
Clinical Center group they took a look
at studies with procalcitonin guided
antibiotic use and compared in hospital
mortality in order to be concluded in
this Venn analysis it had to be patients
with high rates of critical illness and
they had to have mortality as a
significant signal in their cohorts and
when you start looking at this the
overall risk ratio at the bottom here
favors we use a procalcitonin in
reducing mortality although I think what
we would all agree that the effect is
modest
so now we're going to switch over
host response from procalcitonin as a
component of the hosts response and now
look specifically at kovat 19
ghovat 19 is caused by the severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
there is clearly still a lack of
knowledge of several important aspects
of Sarek ob2 infection ranging from the
pathogen biology to the host response
and the treatment options
therefore much of what we talk about and
put in context for copa90
our inferences on the basis of parallel
pathophysiological and ideological
features of other coronaviruses which
have been targeting the lower
respiratory tract but there have been
some new insights into the paths of
biology so because there's this
challenge I wanted to review briefly the
path of biology of infections with Kovac
19
these figures which are out of a great
review in the nature review of
immunology at April 28th and since we're
talking about koban 19 you're going to
see my references are going to become
month specific because the field is
moving so quickly in this schema you can
see that stars
Koby to infect cells expressing the
surface receptor angiotensin converting
enzyme to the ACE to acceptors and also
requires the presence of a transmembrane
proteins your into our tempura stew
when it's been infected with this
combination of the ace 2 receptor and
tempers 2
des Excel will undergo pyroptosis which
is inflammatory cell death and release
the damage associated molecular patterns
including things like ADP nucleic acid
and a ASC on MERS these
associated molecular patterns are
recognized by neighboring epithelial
cells endothelial cells and available or
macrophages and then this triggers a
whole pro-inflammatory cytokine and
chemo kind response involving things
such as I am six macrophage inflammatory
protein one alpha and other MIT proteins
these proteins then attract monocytes
macrophages and T cells to the site of
the infection this promotes further
inflammation and establishes a
pro-inflammatory feedback
at this point immune response similar to
sepsis can either be classified as
dysfunctional
a fatal or adaptive and healthy
if you if you look at the effective or
dysfunctional response
this will quickly lead to a further
accumulation of these immune cells and
lungs causing overproduction upon a
pro-inflammatory cytokine which to a
chemical process will damage the lung
infrastructure
in addition this cytokine storm will
move from the lungs surround other
organs and be disseminated throughout
the body causing multi organ damage an
important component is that non-root
realizing antibodies produced by b-cells
may further enhance the infection
through antibody dependent enhancement
this will further cause organ damage so
that's the dysfunctional immune response
the host response that can lead to some
of the catastrophic challenges a
Tsarskoe v2 that we've seen the scope of
nineteen pandemic including lung injury
and death on the other hand the healthy
response is one in which virus specific
t-cells are attracted the site of
infection they can then eliminate these
cells before the virus spreads
neutralizing antibodies are produced
which can block viral infection and
together all these processes can lead to
the clearance of the virus and minimal
lung damage resulting in recovery
this vein clinically well this is a
clarification of some of the many papers
and again I'm going to get to very month
specific data because this is an
evolving picture but these are the
patients that we see presenting the
hospitals being admitted to ICU and
frankly the ones at risk for dying of
Kovan 19 they predominately have fever
they have coughs they have fatigue
developments of dyspnea some have
anorexia myalgia chills and sore throat
they frequently present with tachycardia
although only 48 percent and rate recent
large series but they do present what to
get Nia with rates as high as 83%
radiologically there are some
characteristics that appear to be unique
to covin 19 and stars Kobe - infection
the first one is that there can be
minimal x-ray findings in the early
stage and therefore CT is recommended
and when you look at the chest CT though
these will be these peripherally
distributed multifocal ground-glass or
passages with patchy consolidations and
I'm going to show you an example of that
and then when you do radio laboratory
assessment you find higher levels of
d-dimer c-reactive protein and
procalcitonin in those with mark disease
severity another component is
lymphopenia with neutrophilia in severe
cases along with some characteristic
changes and things like lactate
dehydrogenase now I'm going to focus in
on these laboratory I need first
this is an overview of a meta-analysis
which is pretty remarkable given this
early stage of the pandemic that
appeared in April of 2020 I'm going to
highlight two specific areas of the
meta-analysis on those patients that are
most severe and contrast the findings of
severe patients require an ICU care
versus those that are either not
hospitalized or not and that is the ICU
the first one is going to be this
component of lymphocytes where
lymphocyte counts are significantly
lower in patients in ICU and across
these studies you can see they're down
to 0.4 0.8 point seven point eight
percent with the size markedly lower
than expected normal number side
distribution in contrast d-dimer's are
consistently elevated in these ICU
patients across these studies with
ranges from two point four to four point
one and those hospitalized ICU
LDH is also elevated consistently in
these ICU patients in these case series
with four levels of 404 35 in those
admitted to the ICU versus normal ranges
and then finally procalcitonin is
elevated and I'm get three different
classifications of the procalcitonin
all is the first so that overall in the
cohort for example in the home study is
8% of all the patients have elevated
procalcitonin those in the ICU had 25
percent of them had elevated pro
calcitonin this is greater than 0.5
nanograms per milliliter and then in the
on I non ICU patients 0% and so that's
the way to look across these four
studies and we're going to focus in on
procalcitonin specifically a little
later in the presentation but you can
see pretty consistently that
procalcitonin is elevated at 25% ICU
patients in HoN study long study at 75
percent gang study it's 50% and then in
the largest trial on the far end its 14%
and the numbers are significant in that
study and that the bomb study had over a
thousand patients the overall number was
elevated PCT was five percent those in
the ICU was 14 percent and this non ICU
patient was 3 percent
this is the test rated graph and CT
images of one of the first patients with
stars Kobe - I just want you to focus in
on the chest x-ray and the upper left
you see that it's relatively clear lung
fields and frankly even them the one on
the right is relatively clear it's only
when you get to the CT scan that you
realize that they have these
ground-glass
opacities filling the the lung spaces
and it's pretty consistent in striking
it marks a big difference between the
chest x-ray appearance and the CT
appearance of these patients early and
SARS Kobe - infection
another key component that's reflected
in this one pathology is just been the
micro vascular alteration on the upper
left is a normal kind of micro
vasculature of the lung shown on
electron microscopy and immediately on
the upper right you see the destruction
in a patient with kovat 19
more remarkable is on the right lower
side on the electron microwave my
program you can see there is a clot
inside the micro vasculature and it's
difficult to tell on this slide that
this little box off to the right
demonstrates the presence of a viral
particle at the nightís of the clot
inside the micro capillary of the lung
this is a distinctive feature of Kovan
19 vs. say another severe influenza like
influenza A h1n1 and a recent paper than
knowing internal literally ten days ago
demonstrated that in patients with kovat
19 there is a distinct change in this
end angiogenesis from those patients
with koba 19 verses prior patients with
influenza A the kovat 19 data are in red
the influenza A data are in blue and you
can see across many different parameters
of angiogenesis and characterization of
lung pathology that koban 19 is
distinctive from influenza A
there may be a laboratory correlate of
this response in the form of elevated
d-dimer's this is a recent meta-analysis
that came out of thrombosis in 2020 this
was just published online in May and it
basically showed that for patients who
have more severe forms of coded 19
require an ICU care that the weighted
mean difference between those patients
and patients with less severe forms is
elevated with a mean difference of over
three indeed Eimer levels and I think
that this may be a important component
as we move forward in characterizing the
host response a patients with severe
kovat 19
what about procalcitonin in these
patients with suspected coded 19 most of
the data is coming out of China
the data still evolving but there have
been a number of large theories
presented out of the Chinese experience
the first one was out of multiple
Chinese prominent provinces which was
published in February and it showed that
c-reactive protein was elevated 60% of
patients elevated PCT was found in 5.5
percent of the patients an elevated
lactate dehydrogenase was elevated in 41
percent of the patients with severe
disease in the blue Honda experience
nonsurvivors as compared to survivors
presented more often with high lactate
dehydrogenase higher procalcitonin
increased serum ferritin and elevated
il-6 and then Zhejiang University noted
that they had good results within
emergency department protocol that
included antimicrobial prophylaxis only
in patients with long course of disease
repeated paper repeated excuse me
repeated fever and elevated
procalcitonin
look at what the summary of these
studies and this is now a review that
came out in the american journal
hematology in 2020 april you see that
there are these consistent finally of
increased procalcitonin and more severe
patient I'll just highlight the key
results of each of these studies
first studied procalcitonin was elevated
in 13% of severe cases versus 3.7
percent in non severe cases
the next series elevated procalcitonin
appeared in 25% of ICU cases versus 0%
and non ICU cases
procalcitonin was present 75% of ICU
cases versus 20% and non ICU cases
and that elevated procalcitonin had a
higher odds ratio of death with an odds
ratio estimated at thirteen point seven
five
another study out of Seattle in ICU
patients baseline procalcitonin had a
wide range but range from point one to
up to nine point five six nanograms
familiar
finally that elevator procalcitonin had
a higher odds of severe infection in
clinical course in this case the odds
ratio was estimated at four point seven
six
so I think that it's clear that
procalcitonin in suspected covered
ninety needy patients is clearly going
to be of some importance
overall the host response differs
between those with bacterial and viral
infections and we've seen that in our
large cohort studies of looking at my
tat alone proteomics and gene expression
in addition to procalcitonin
for multiple men analyses the
procalcitonin can help distinguish
bacterial infection and potentially
guide antibiotic use especially in
patients who are more severe requiring
ICU care and with higher baseline
mortality
occurrence read of all these data on
Ovid 19 is that procalcitonin is
generally low in presentations of
patients with non severe cope at 19
while it appears to be consistently
elevated to more severe disease
I still think there
or questions about the role of
procalcitonin in kovat 19 including them
patients an emergency department was
suspected ghovat 19 there's a need to
better understand the host response to
Coba 19 infection including the
induction of host response elements like
procalcitonin we need to better define
the role of low procalcitonin in
patients with the initial presentation
of kovat 19
third we need to understand the role of
bacterial super infection in patients
with cope at 19 and finally we need to
understand the relationship between this
consistently elevated procalcitonin
found in these studies and the increased
severity of kovat 19 illness
with that I'm happy to
questions providing further comments but
most of all thank you all for joining us
today for this discussion of an
important topic to code in nineteen the
role of procalcitonin and how we might
take on the challenges this pandemic
together
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions as a reminder any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via they contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank you dr. Cairns for
your time today in your important
research we would also like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor bo marrow for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this Web seminar can be viewed on-demand
laborat will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye